[Music]
american hospitals face a double threat
more coveted patients than ever
including children and more doctors and
nurses off sick with the virus as the
hospitals get strained
there is less opportunity to to provide
all these resources to the one single
patient
the incredible surge in covet cases
averaging more than six hundred thousand
per day is also taking a toll on
everyday life
public transit systems have slashed
service with drivers unavailable
airlines continue to cancel thousands of
flights due to staffing shortages
there's even a shortage of lab workers
to process coveted tests the next few
weeks and possibly even into the month
of february are going to be pretty
dismal because we are projecting surges
in other parts of the country that will
peak in the next two to four weeks in an
op-ed in the journal of the american
medical association several former
advisors to president joe biden called
for a new strategy writing covet 19 is
here to stay policy makers need to
specify the goals and strategies for the
new normal of life i don't think covert
is here to stay biden has so far
resisted calls for any drastic shift in
approach rejecting measures like vaccine
mandates for air travel we're going to
be able to control this the new normal
is not going to be what it is now it's
going to be better how the u.s gets to
that better place remains uncertain
omicron's extraordinary spread has not
changed the fundamental problems with
the u.s response
vaccination and booster campaigns are
still lagging and forecast suggests the
u.s death toll could top 1 million by
march
jackson prosko global news washington